next we have chintzy appealing Jerry she
is the executive director of Kota the
center for digital archive archaeology
she is an archaeologist and educator and
cultural heritage she has a PhD in
archaeology from the University of
Naples she has collaborated in a number
of field projects mostly in Africa and
taught undergraduate and graduate
courses in Italy Ethiopia and Bahrain
before moving to the United States in
2008 she was a visiting scholar at the
University of California at Berkeley in
2011 she co-founded the Center for
Digital archaeology which is a
successful California not-for-profit
company dedicated to engage in
communities individuals and
professionals with cultures from
heritage sites to family memories thank
you for joining us thank you thank you
Alan thank you to the organizers for
inviting me and thank you all for being
here for my talk it is really a great
pleasure for me to be at this conference
it was also a little bit of a challenge
to prepare for it as I thought at first
that my humanistic perspective would be
a little bit too distant from the
conference focus on machine learning and
big data in general much of what we do
at the Center for Digital archeology has
to do with stories sometimes very small
stories stories about things that cannot
be easily replaced like an
archaeological site a monument a
collection a disappearing language or a
tradition that needs to be told before
it's too late we find the best way to
document these stories digitally in a
way that hopefully will survive for
generations and we teach communities to
do it themselves this small stories all
together compose that complex and
beautiful mosaic that is our human
experience on earth as humans since the
dawn of time we have cared very much
about producing information about
ourselves we do that all the time and as
we try to understand information that
has already been produced either few
minutes ago or back or back into
millennia we keep producing information
all of us aim at recuperating that
information making sense of it and
purpose and repurposing it ultimately
archaeologists data analysts and
innovators in Big Data aim at a common
higher purpose get insights into human
behavior that will ultimately lead to
learning to informing our decisions and
to being more strategic about our
actions in this respect I would say that
we are all humanists you're welcome so
how are we doing with digital
preservation of cultural heritage and
what can be done better I will not focus
on the methods and standards of the
digital preservation per se i will tell
some stories i will share our experience
at Khoda and highlight some ideas for
more sustainable and meaningful
preservation of digital heritage with a
potential for a much larger social
impact it is probably so thousands of
years we used clay and stone and it
lasted forever hundreds of years
parchment still here today we deal with
the femoral world of digital and we face
the issues of digital preservation it is
probably worth reminding us that digital
preservation is still working progress
so all of us that are producing data
that cannot be replaced have a
responsibility to keeping it safe until
we do figure that out dumping or backing
up our data into an archive or on any
storage device is not an adequate data
preservation strategy not only we need
to make primary data reusable so that it
continues to function as operating
systems evolve but also we need to
create sufficient metadata explaining
the context in which the information has
been created we are making great
progress in identifying the factors that
influence the feasibility and cost of
preserving cultural information in the
face of future
technological change these are some of
the factors that have been identified by
the Library of Congress and we are also
working our way towards strategy for
future preservation action like
replication of content or new media in
migration and normalization
unfortunately most or all of the efforts
at the federal institutional and private
repositories level to address long-term
digital preservation of cultural content
are not scalable at this time not in the
size and scale that we would need a tad
economy conference in 2010 at Lake Tahoe
Eric Schmidt google CEO rattled off a
massive statistic every two days now we
create as much information as we did
from the dawn of civilization up until
two thousand three so the real issue is
usual generated content and in
archaeology and heritage it's no
different or shouldn't be then you know
there are any other domain of our lives
the all-digital workflows that we use to
record our archaeology and heritage
today are changing the format of our
records raw data and analysis field
notes of photographs drawings are now
born digital documents three-dimensional
imaging data sets and virtual reality
products that are commonly used in
archaeology and heritage today create
massive sets of data that all encounter
a big bottleneck to be ingested in
existing repositories this is a curation
life cycle model that we have developed
at code and that represents the main
steps that we believe should be involved
in a complete process of digital
curation but in the practice data
formats data structures vocabularies the
storage space are all limitations to the
sustainability and scalability of
existing repositories for example we
have been very
working on a project in collaboration
with the National Center for
preservation technology and training of
the NPS of the National Park Service to
survey the state of the art of digital
documentation for historical buildings
and sites and landscapes across the NPS
the Bureau of Land Management and
related agencies and to understand the
dissemination and training needs of the
professionals across these agencies that
are charged with ingesting digital data
for the documentation of our historical
building now it needs to be said that
the Secretary of the Interior standards
and guidelines for archaeology and
historical preservation it is an actual
thing it's never been republished since
1983 now the NPS is doing an amazing job
in taking in tackling issues around
preserving CAD and GIS files poor legal
mesh point clouds digital elevation
models augmented and virtual reality
products in the lack of expert and
structured guidance I will not discuss
the results of this project because it's
a work in progress by our colleagues at
NPS but we release a report with
interviews and an assessment but the
point here is that we clearly have a big
urgent need of thinking everything and
cultural heritage preservation for today
and for the future now we are in fact
starting to talk about big data also in
our fields and we are not prepared for
that size and we are only tackling
official data there are on the radar of
major institutions and this makes me
think about what we all intend as data
intrinsic kind of dry information about
the appearance of things their geometry
a bunch of measurements specifically for
monuments for instance how tall how big
the shape of that particular
architectural feature the material the
textured
technique all very important information
but in a way through our present concept
of data we are stating that all we need
to know about the pyramid FK up when it
will not be there for us to see anymore
is how it look like or its geometry now
how many of us here are familiar with
this type of image with the idea of the
building of the pyramids as the efforts
of thousands of slaves working for the
tantrum zuv one man under very poor
conditions until death and replacement
this is pretty much the idea that we
have of about how the pyramids were
built well years of archaeological
research are telling us a very different
stories story and I apologize this is
not the best photo it's just a small
tiny glimpse of the village of Giza very
close to the pyramids just by the
pyramids that we're archaeological
excavations are revealing an entire
society of workers of men women children
elders gathering places breweries and
bakeries very decent tombs for all with
all the right formulas and the right
God's overlooking to make a fair journey
in the afterlife Egyptian style this was
an entire society of people that had
chosen to be part of something
unprecedented but they came likely from
all parts of Egypt not as captives but
willing eager to build the greatest
testimonial of Egyptian culture to last
forever so this narrative we agree is as
important as the geometry of the pyramid
itself we must find a way to catch this
complexity to preserve as many
narratives as possible around our
monuments and sites together with their
digital surrogates let coda we're trying
to do our part we focus on two main
fields that we
digital field archaeology and
traditional knowledge we help
archaeologists and communities identify
the right tools and solutions to take
care of the digital information that
they produce in some cases we partner
with institutions and companies to help
develop the right technology I want to
share with you in small snapshots some
of the successful stories that we've
been working on or we are working on we
have been working on with archaeologists
this is jay BRP the jezreel valley
archaeological project in israel and
we're working with em to fully realize
the potential of paperless recording for
the entire workflow including
three-dimensional imaging from from
photographs with training and a
combination of low-tech and high-tech
gear it is possible to produce
astounding results that are usual for
analysis and knowledge production
writing the field the process is still
somehow painstaking but produces results
with errors that can be measured in
millimeters across areas that are
measures in meters and more and with
everything to scale these results can be
combined to produce a better picture of
what is happening below the ground as
well as on it but there is much room for
improvement in terms of scaling these
techniques about in terms of speed and
productivity we are also highly
motivated to work on cultural projects
that are impacted also by natural risks
in natural risks that are increasing due
to climate change such as cycling Pam
which displays the 75,000 people on the
small island of Vanuatu in the South
Pacific while most of their sites are
sacred on the island that the local
population as well as the archeologists
in partnership realize the importance of
sharing this information broadly we
partnered with them to create an online
community archive where the ninety-five
percent of the content is completely
open access
only the sacred rock art sites related
content is available only to local
researchers and the endo archive is in
three languages also in bislama which is
the local language on the island of
Vanuatu a kind of a surprising example
so for us when it came out as a project
wars are fought by people are fought by
sons fathers daughters and mothers in
remembrance of world war one Cardiff
University won a grant to commemorate
the memories of those who fought on
fronts that are rarely thought about in
the larger narrative of the great war to
date 42 individuals have contributed the
project kicked off about a month ago 40
days ago 42 individuals have contributed
16 Android images postcards and growing
postcards photo album albums and other
physical and digital memorabilia to help
humanize the stories of these soldiers
in the travels throughout Egypt Israel
and Palestine we are building together
an offline solution together and share
these materials that will eventually
sink with an online archive these are
some examples of tangible heritage how
about intangible languages poems oral
traditions how we are preserving this
some examples the native Alutiiq
language has a beautiful sound a complex
grammar and is a very ancient tradition
is the best language in fact to
represent and describe the history of
the oolitic people of the Kodiak region
in Alaska there are only 33 fluent
native oolitic speakers living today if
we don't do something about them the
oolitic language will die in less than
50 years and no memory of knowledge or
knowledge of it will survive the illogic
music took on the looting Museum took on
the char
revitalizing the language by
recuperating large collections of
recordings and sharing them with all
community members to learn to
acknowledge their origin and preserve
their traditions we have partnered with
the Alutiiq museum to help create a
workflow for recording and expanding the
language and for sharing and archiving
the recordings through an accessible web
web portal all this while doing training
so they take that it's sustainable that
they can keep doing it themselves and
this is another case Kivalina is a small
community in northwest alaska now no
matter what we believe about climate
change these people need a new place to
live because the permafrost is melting
and entire villages are falling into the
sea this is an ongoing project that we
are conducting with two groups based in
Alaska relocate Kivalina and three
degrees warmer we are developing
together a living archive of history and
cultural practice and traditional
knowledge and my last example we mirror
the Kanak stock route project we were
fortunate enough to partner a few years
back to develop this project with some
groups in Australia now the the area
covered by the mirror project is like
most of Australia sacred and Syria has a
sacred and serious significance to many
Aboriginal communities the title of this
project mirror means bringing something
in hidden into the light we have created
a very rich community archive that
gathers the works of over 200 artists
mixed with local traditions and the
sacred or rock art sites these are the
numbers of the projects and growing now
let me tell you that these stories feel
like small miracles given the limited
resources that we have to work with and
I forgot to wear the black slides to
represent all the stories that I cannot
tell I really forgot that i cannot tell
because we couldn't get it done because
we cannot scale because we didn't have
the time
because we didn't have the resources so
we do need a redefinition of data in our
humanities domain as a concept inclusive
not only of professionally produced
content but inclusive of alternative
narratives and community driven
contributions to heritage if we think
that a handful of institutions companies
and archaeologists will preserve our
culture for posterity we learn the wrong
path we need to be more mindful of the
impact and scale of our projects and i'm
not talking about scaling 200 projects
in 400 projects 200 projects 220 is the
number of projects that we have done at
cola in five years i am talking about
scaling 200 projects in 200,000 or 200
millions of projects we need to teach
people how to do some of this themselves
and in order to scale this much we need
something we need you you and we
probably need to also rethink the
definition of big data is not only
machine based produced information but a
world of knowledge also inclusive of a
more humanistic approach that together
with machine-based the streams of ones
and zeros includes the depth of the
context the power of storytelling and a
higher level of quality for archival
information we need a combination of
public and private interests to support
this development we need your powerful
and unparalleled familiarity with the
processing data at a large scale and
with creating tools based on human
behavior everything we have been
learning during these years of working
with communities heritage points to the
need of constructing new modes of
interpreting and circulating knowledge
that yes our ethical and yes are
constructed on small stories but also
they need to allow analysis or a big
pattern
and preservation and interpret and
interpretation and multiple scales when
we are no more how digital memories
shaping our future is the title of a
beautiful book written by abby smith
ramsey an expert of digital data
collection and curation and consultant
to the library of congress among other
things she says the fundamental purpose
of recording our memories to ensure they
live beyond our brief decades on earth
will be lost in the ephemeral digital
landscape if we do not become our own
data managers the skills to control our
personal information over the course of
our lives are essential to digital
literacy and scholarship these
statements are very important are and
have deep anthropological roots they
speak directly to the idea of a new
digital democracy based on which digital
preservation of cultural heritage is not
the responsibility of you it's a mission
and a right for all of us only large
community efforts can effectively
address the complex tasks involved into
preserving cultures digitally heritage
is a big mission for all we are cultural
beings if we lose our heritage and
cannot save the memory of it we will
have lost the most profound expression
of our civilizations I believe this
completely and i will keep doing my part
hopefully with the help of some of you
thank
you